all right let's get right into it very
important 2022 race fetterman versus Oz
Pennsylvania Senate television quack Dr
Mehmet Oz is the Republican Senate
nominee in Pennsylvania running against
him as the Democratic Lieutenant
Governor John fetterman much has been
made by the Oz people about fetterman
having a stroke and fetterman uh needing
special medical accommodations for
debates and all of these horrible
different things and increasingly Oz has
just looked really like a bad guy and
there is a new poll that looks very bad
for Mehmet Oz but we try to pay
attention to the average of recent polls
and never Focus too much on any one poll
but let's go in order new poll
fetterman ahead of Oz with a
double-digit lead writes Newsweek
when you look at the details this is a
new Marist poll published earlier this
week 51 percent of registered voters in
Pennsylvania support fetterman compared
to 41 percent who support Oz 7
undecided this is a good number for
fetterman however if you go to likely
voters I'm sorry definite voters in
November Oz gets 44 with fetterman 51
and 4 percent undecided however when we
look at the averages of recent polls you
see that fetterman's lead is an average
of four and a half points
again we want to see this as glass glass
half full or do we want to see this as
glass half empty and the questions are
always very similar well the glass have
full perspective is
fetterman's winning and it's outside the
margin of error the glass half empty is
how on Earth
does a TV doctor from a different state
who has no business even running never
mind being in the Senate have an average
of 44 of the expected Pennsylvania
electorate saying yeah I'm gonna go with
the quack TV doctor from Jersey
glass half full glass half empty you
tell me the important thing is assume
absolutely nothing and make sure that
you vote there are important deadlines
in Pennsylvania the deadline for
in-person registration at local election
offices is October 24th that's three and
a half weeks away
uh the deadline to register online is
October 24th and the deadline to
register by mail is your request must be
received by October 24th so October 24th
is the important number in Pennsylvania
now for absentee ballots you must
request your ballot no later than
November 1 by 5 PM it must be received
your return ballot by mail meaning when
you vote must be received November 8th
by 8 PM that's when polls close in
Pennsylvania if you don't send it early
enough for it to be received by that
time
it's not going to be counted and then
lastly to turn in your ballot in person
or vote in person it is November 8th by
8 PM polls close 8 P.M on Election Day
in Pennsylvania
extraordinarily important election when
we ask the question as many of us often
do
on which state might Democratic control
of the Senate hinge one of the most
likely outcomes is that if indeed
Democratic control hinges on only one
state that state will be Pennsylvania so
these midterms we never want to say
races don't matter of course tons of
races matter but both gubernatorially
and sanatorially Pennsylvania is
dramatically important I hope all of our
Pennsylvania listeners are registered or
you're going to get registered by
October 24th and you're going to vote
not only is the Senate vote important
but I will again take the opportunity to
remind you the gubernatorial race and we
will be covering a debate between
Shapiro and mastriano
the Republican nominee in Pennsylvania
for the Governor's race Doug mastriano
yes he has a history of dressing like a
confederate soldier it's disgusting yeah
he's vile disgusting guy fine but put
that aside for a second
he is overtly
a guy who will try to steal Pennsylvania
for the Republican presidential
candidate in 2024 no matter who wins he
has said he was in DC on January 6th he
has said he believes Trump actually won
in Pennsylvania even though he didn't he
didn't get more votes but somehow
mastriano thinks Trump won
if in 2024
you have a tight election in
Pennsylvania and the Democratic
Presidential nominee wins if mastriano
is the governor he will try to steal
those electoral votes for the Republican
even if the Republican didn't win I
don't know how else to say it I don't
know how else to explain it to people
this is an emergency in Pennsylvania
I think I've said enough register
make sure you know where your polling
place is do not forget to vote one of
our sponsors is paired the app for
couples every day paired gives you and
your partner questions quizzes games to
have fun to stay connected to deepen
your conversations and get to know each
other better what's great about it is
you don't even have to be in the same
room especially with the baby right now
my girlfriend and I are quite busy and
paired really helped us to stay
connected you get a daily question to
answer you can't see your partner's
answer until you answer yourself and
their questions about everything
relationship life intimacy other things
and all of the exercises were developed
by academic psychologists and expert
relationship therapists as well
questions like what makes you feel lucky
in your relationship great when you want
to remember and have gratitude a really
great thing what's an activity you could
try together this month actually gets
people thinking about things to do it
can go in really funny directions as
well but it just always feels like time
well spent go to paired.com Pacman to
download the app and get a seven day
free trial the link is down below